ON THE 12TH, DOES NOT MEAN THAT
IT GETS ALL DONE AT ONE MEETING.
MAYBE YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SECOND
OR THIRD.
MAYBE WE WILL HAVE NONE!
>> Bret: MULTIPLE SUMMITS?
WE HAVE SEEN THAT BEFORE.
BY THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT
THIS POSSIBLE SUMMIT ON
JUNE 12TH, IF IT STAYS, TALKING
TO REUTERS ON AIR FORCE ONE, I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT DONE IN ONE
MEETING, BUT OFTENTIMES THAT IS
NOT THE WAY THAT THE DEAL WORKS.
THERE IS A VERY GOOD CHANCE THAT
IT WILL NOT BE DONE IN ONE
MEETING OR TWO MEETINGS OR THREE
MEETINGS, BUT IT WILL GET DONE
AT SOME POINT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
LETTER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO JUNE 12, WHERE
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A TOTAL
DENUCLEARIZATION AND AS QUICK AS
PRACTICABLE.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT MACHINERY.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT CANNOT HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY,
BUT THEY CAN HAPPEN IN AS RAPID
A FASHION AS THEY CAN HAPPEN.
THAT IS WHAT I WANT TO HAPPEN.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL, START
THERE.
JONATHAN SWANN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS,
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY.
A SENIOR EDITOR AT THE
FEDERALIST COMING IN CHARLES
LANE, OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
I SENSE THAT THERE IS KIND OF A
SETTING OF EXPECTATIONS HERE OF
WHAT COULD BE A FIRST IN A
SERIES THAT THEY DO NOT THINK
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO GET IT
ALL IN ONE.
>> I TALKED TO A SENIOR
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL YESTERDAY
THEY SAY THAT TODAY ARE STILL
HOPING THAT IT IS JUNE 12, BUT
THERE IS STILL SOME UNCERTAINTY,
THERE WERE NOT DETAILS WITH
NORTH KOREA, IT COULD BE PUSHED
OUT BY A FEW DAYS.
AND OF COURSE, WHO KNOWS, IF KIM
JONG UN, SOMETHING COULD HAPPEN
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN THAT BLOWS
NO BOLTING UP.
>> Bret: IT IS SIGNIFICANT AT
THIS TOP GUY IS COMING.
TO THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> VERY SIGNIFICANT.
AND WORKING UNDER THE ASSUMPTION
THAT THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN,
THE PRESIDENT WANTS IT TO
HAPPEN.
AND EVEN THE SKEPTICS ON HIS
TEAM LIKE JOHN BOLTON, NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR KNOWS THAT THE
PRESIDENCY IS A PATH HERE.
AND THEY ARE NOT FIGHTING THE
DECISION.
>> Bret: IT DOES NOT MATTER
THE DATE OF JUNE 12, IT MATTERS
WHAT THEY GET OUT OF IT.
AND IF THEY GET OUT OF IT.
>> THERE IS A PATTERN IN HISTORY
WHERE YOU HAVE A REALLY LONG
LEAD UP TO A MEETING.
WORK OUT AND YOU NEGOTIATE WHAT
WILL BE DISCUSSED.
THEN YOU HOPE FOR THE BEST I
WILL HAVE AN EDIT WEEDING.
ONE GETS THE SENSE BECAUSE WE
HAVE HAD SUCH BAD COMMUNICATION,
MAY BE JUST MEETING AND GETTING
THINGS STARTED RIGHT AWAY WILL
BE HELPFUL EVEN THOUGH I DO NOT
THINK THAT TERRIBLY MUCH WILL BE
ACCOMPLISHED SO EARLY THAT IT
WILL TAKE FURTHER MEETINGS AND
MORE HASHING OUT.
AND IF WE DID HERE BEFORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CANCELED A
MEETING THAT NORTH KOREA HAVE
PROPOSED SIMILAR THINGS ALONG
THE LINE TO WHAT THEY HAVE
PROPOSED IN THE PAST.
WHEN THEY GET A BIG BUNDLE OF
MONEY FOR PROMISING TO DO
SOMETHING.
I DO NOT THINK THAT THAT WILL
SATISFY THE U.S. NEGOTIATORS
THIS TIME AROUND.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME, THE
RUSSIANS ARE MAKING A MOVE TO
NORTH KOREA.
>> HE SENDS HIS WARMEST REGARDS
AND BEST WISHES AND THE
ENDEAVORS THAT HAVE BEEN
INITIATED ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA WITH YOUR
PARTICIPATION.
THE SITUATION ON THE CAN KOREAN
PENINSULA IS CHANGING ACCORDING
THAT PUTIN'S GOVERNMENT IS
ACTING IN OPPOSITION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE READY TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE RUSSIAN SIDE.
>> PIECE, PER VILLAGE HE, AND
PROSPERITY IN SOUTHEAST IN
GENERAL ARE IN OUR INTEREST.
>> Bret: WARM AND FUZZY WITH
KIM JONG UN, CLEARLY SENDING A
MESSAGE THAT WE ARE STILL
AROUND.
>> WE ARE STILL AROUND, WE ARE
STILL ON YOUR BORDER.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON.
YES, IT IS A BIG EVENT, WHATEVER
IT WAS ON THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE HE IS GETTING
SERIOUS BETWEEN YOU AND
DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT IS VERY INTERESTING ABOUT
THAT LITTLE MEETING IS THAT IT
SHOWS KIM JONG UN HAS SOMEHOW
MANAGED TO PUT HIMSELF, IT'S ON
THE PSYCHE IS COURTING, HE IS
SORT OF THE MOST ELIGIBLE
BACHELOR IN NORTHEAST ASIA, AND
EVERYBODY IS COMING TO HIM TO
SEE WHAT HE WANTS.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE YOU
HAPPY.
TRYING TO GET INFLUENCE WITH
HIM.
I THINK THAT THAT IS A VERY
STRONG POSITION FOR HIM TO BE
IN.
THE UNITED STATES HAS QUITE
OPENLY SAID, IF YOU DO BUSINESS
WITH US, IF YOU GIVE US WHAT WE
WANT, WE ARE PREPARED TO
GUARANTEE YOUR SAFETY, MAKE YOU
RICH.
THE PRESIDENT EVEN SAID, MAKE
YOU HAPPY.
AND THAT IS A VERY SWEET OFFER
THAT PROBABLY ALARMS THE
RUSSIANS AND THE CHINESE A
LITTLE BIT THAT MAY BE THE
UNITED STATES, MY GOSH, WILL
TURN OUT TO BE THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL POWER RIGHT HERE IN
NORTHEAST ASIA.
AND THEY ARE MOVING TO CHECK IT
OUT.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME, WE
ARE STILL CHECKING THE RUSSIA
PROBE ON A LOT OF DIFFERENT
FRONTS.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING TODAY A
NUMBER OF TWEETS, BUT THIS ONE,
NOT THAT IT MATTERS WHAT I NEVER
FIRED JAMES COMEY BECAUSE OF
RUSSIA.
THE CORRUPT MAINSTREAM MEDIA
LOVES TO KEEP PUSHING THAT
NARRATIVE, BUT THEY KNOW THAT IT
IS NOT TRUE.
THAT PROMPTED A LOT OF LOOKING
INTO SOUND BITES.
LIKE THIS ONE FROM NBC.
>> REGARDLESS OF RECOMMENDATION,
I WAS GOING TO FIRE COMEY,
KNOWING THAT THERE WAS NO GOOD
TIME TO DO IT.
IN FACT, WHEN I DECIDED TO JUST
DO IT, I SAID TO MYSELF, I SAID,
YOU KNOW, THIS RUSSIAN THING
WITH TRUMP AND RUSSIA IS A MADE
UP STORY, IT IS A EXCUSE BY THE
DEMOCRATS FOR HER LOST
INCORPORATED LOSING AN ELECTION
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE WON.
>> Bret: WHAT IS THE DEAL?
DID YOU FIGURE OUT THE
WHITE HOUSE RESPONSE?
>> THEY ARE NOT TALKING MUCH ON
THIS.
I ACTUALLY DID SOME REPORTING
TODAY ON OTHER CONVERSATIONS
THAT TRUMP HAS BEEN HAVING
PRIVATELY, PRESSURING JEFF
SESSIONS FOR THE BETTER PART OF
A YEAR OVER THIS.
THEY ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT IT.
I DO NOT THINK THAT THERE IS A
PARTICULARLY GOOD ANSWER FOR
THAT COMMENT.
>> THERE IS A GREAT ANSWER, IF
YOU DO THE CLIP JUST A LITTLE
BIT LONGER HE TALKS ABOUT MORE
THAT HE KNOWS THAT FIRING COMEY
MIGHT EXTEND THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
BUT IT STILL MUST BE DONE.
THAT CLIP IS NOT THAT DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND PIT HE IS SAYING
THAT HE DID NOT LIKE HOW JAMES
COMEY WAS PRIVATELY ASSURING HIM
THAT HE WAS NOW THE TARGET OF A
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION WHILE
PUBLICLY SUGGESTING TO THE WORLD
THAT HE
WAS.
EVEN THOUGH JAMES COMEY WAS
DOING THESE J. EDGAR HOOVER TYPE
OF GAMES IT MIGHT CAUSE HIM
TROUBLE ON THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, HE NEEDED TO FIRE
HIM BECAUSE HE WAS SO BAD AT HIS
JOB AND BECAUSE HE WAS BAD FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I THINK PARTICULARLY WITH WHAT
WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT JAMES
COMEY IN THE YEAR SINCE THAT
INTERVIEW WAS GIVEN, WHICH I
THINK WAS JUST ABOUT A YEAR AGO
NOW, WE REALLY SHOULD HAVE A
CLEAR UNDERSTAND OF WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
>> Bret: SURE, BUT THEY DO NOT
HAVE YOU TALKING FOR THEM AND
THEY DO NOT HAVE YOU EXPLAINING
IT TO.
WHEN THE TWEETS COMES OUT, IT IS
NOT THAT CLEAR.
SO A LOT OF TIMES YOU HAVE TO
READ BETWEEN --
>> I WILL NOT DISAGREE WITH YOU
THAT THEY COULD DO A BETTER JOB
MESSAGING WHAT IS BEING SAID.
AND PUTTING OUT WHAT THAT WHOLE
INTERVIEW WAS SHOWN.
>> IT IN THE MEANTIME RUDY
GIULIANI IS GOING AFTER TREY
GOWDY ON WHAT HE SAID OF THE
INFORMANT OR SPY, TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I WENT TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS
THAT TREY GOWDY HAS NEVER SEEN,
WHICH IS OUTRAGEOUS.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO LET MY
CLIENT TESTIFY, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, EVEN IF HE
WANTS TO WITHOUT THOSE DOCUMENTS
BEING PRODUCED.
IF AND WHEN WE FIND THAT THIS
WAS HANDLED APPROPRIATELY, AND
THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE THAT THEY
CAN BASE THIS ON THE
INVESTIGATION, WE WILL HAVE HIM
TESTIFY.
>> Bret: CHUCKLED.
>> WELL TREY GOWDY DID DELIVER
AT LEAST IN P.R. TERMS A VERY
HEAVY BLOW TO THE TRUMP POSITION
IN THIS BY COMING FORWARD AND
BLESSING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, SORRY, THE FBI
INVESTIGATION PRIOR TO MUELLER,
DURING THE ELECTION.
SO OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE PUSHING
BACK VERY HARD.
I THINK THAT IF I MAY STEP BACK,
WITH WHAT RUDY GIULIANI IS DOING
IS A PIECE THAT WOULD PUT THE
TRUMP TWEET TODAY, PREPARING THE
GROUND ON ALL KINDS OF AREAS FOR
WHAT MIGHT BE THE EVENTUAL
CONFRONTATION WITH MUELLER.
LAYING DOWN MARKERS OF HERE IS
OUR VERSION OF EVENTS.
HERE IS OUR VERSION OF THE
FACTS.
TREY GOWDY GOING TO FOLLOW THAT,
SO THEY PUSH BACK.
>> I WROTE AT "THE FEDERALIST"
THAT TREY GOWDY DID NOT SEE ALL
OF THE SUBPOENAED DOCUMENTS THAT
THEY ARE SEEKING TO USE THE
INFORMANT THAT HE ALSO SEEMS
CONFUSED WHETHER IT WAS A
CRIMINAL PROBE, WE DO NOT USE
THE TERM SPY AND CRIMINAL
PROBES, BUT WE SHOULD ALL KNOW
BECAUSE JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED
ABOUT THIS IN MARCH 2017, THIS
WAS NOT A CRIMINAL PROBE, THIS
WAS A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROBE.
SPIES ARE COMMON IN A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PROBE, WE DO
WITH POLITICAL OPPONENTS DURING
A CAMPAIGN, I THINK IT IS REALLY
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
DISCUSSING.
AND THINKING THROUGH AND KNOWING
SO MUCH MORE ABOUT WHETHER THEY
ARE CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS,
INTERNAL WATCHDOGS, OR PEOPLE IN
THE MEDIA.
>> Bret: WHEN TREY GOWDY HAS
THESE MEETINGS AND AGREE THAT
THEY DID NOT BRING IN ANY
DOCUMENTS, AND THEY HAVE A
CLASSIFIED DEBRIEFING AND THEY
EXPLAIN WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
AND HE SAYS, YOU SHOULD BE PROUD
OF WHAT THE FBI WAS DOING AT THE
TIME, AND YOU WOULD EXPECT THAT.
HOW IS THAT INTERPRETED ANY
OTHER WAY?
>> WELL I AM NOT ENTIRELY SURE
HOW TO EXPLAIN WHAT TREY GOWDY
WAS SAYING.
ALTHOUGH HE DOES HAVE A HISTORY
OF BEING A FAN OF THE FBI.
BUT HE ALSO COMPLETED WHAT HE
WAS SAYING IN THESE INTERVIEWS
ABOUT WHAT'S PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
HAD.
WHEN JAMES COMEY FIRST PRESENTED
TO HIM INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS, WHICH WAS AFTER THE
ELECTION PERIOD HE SAID THAT HE
WOULD LIKE A FULLY INVESTIGATED.
AND TREY GOWDY SAID, THIS MEANS
THAT IT WAS OKAY TO RUN AN
INFORMANT AGAINST YOUR CAMPAIGN.
AND I DO NOT THINK THAT HE
FURTHER SAID THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SUPPORT THE USE OF
INFORMANTS.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A GOOD GRASP ON
WHAT AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK ABOUT
RUNNING INFORMANTS ON POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS.
>> Bret: I WANT TO GET TO THE
REST OF THE PANEL, WE ONLY HAVE
A QUICK AMOUNT OF TIME, BUT
JONATHAN, ALSO TODAY, THE PARDON
OF DINESH DESOUSA, THE PRESIDENT
SAYS THAT HE IS CONSIDERING A
PARDON OF MARTHA STEWART SAYING
THAT THE PRESIDENT USE OF
PARDON POWERS IS CONCERNING
ENOUGH BREAD FOR THE POSSIBILITY
THAT HE MAY BE SENDING A MESSAGE
TO WITNESSES IN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO HIS CAMPAIGN
IS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, NOBODY
IS ABOVE THE LAW.
IS A PART IN A PARDON OR A PART
IN A MESSAGE?
>> I AM A REPORTER, SO I NEED
FACTS.
AND THIS IS THE SAME THING AS
BEFORE, I CAN ONLY REPORT WHAT I
KNOW FOR A FACT.
I DO NOT HAVE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID TO DO